ce que
je m'entendais de 3,4 de trois cadres
sans chichis c'est en déchirure yes
parfait que bomba beaux jours on va
attendre que les gens arrivent petit à
petit bonjour et bienvenue pour ce live
c'est la première fois que je fais un
rêve sur ma chaîne où je vais faire un
peu en mode interactif ont essayé de
faire un truc un peu interactif c'est
cool
très bien du coup je vais poser dès à
présent un problème attendant que les
gens arrivent je vais faire je vais
essayer de décrire donc le problème
c'est suivant c'est on a quatre balles
dont une à un poids différent plus
lourdes ou plus légère et on a une
balance pour faire des pesées
comparative
on met les boules et bas de chacun des
côtés on peut juste voir si ça pour elle
de l'ordre d'un côté ou de l'autre
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
trouver là l'intrus avec deux peser ses
rangs que les gens arrivent comme ça
vous pouvez à réfléchir et vous pouvez
répondre à ce questionnaire donc avec le
premier lieu le premier lien vous pouvez
cliquer dessus et on vous renvoie un
sondage en google forme alors que voix
pour avoir les résultats c'est bien ça
combien est-ce que deux peser suffire en
du cou à tous les coups bas pour trouver
l'intrus est un peu un peu y réfléchir
pendant ce temps je vais aussi de
présenter un peu le plan de ce live donc
aujourd'hui on va faire ça a été un truc
un ouais un peu plus colère que deux tu
dois dire que je prescrire stanhome et
ça va être un peu on va faire on va
faire un peu ça ressort à +1 court que
d'habitude
et donc ce qu'on va faire d'abord qu'on
va parler ah oui un autre truc c'est que
sur le questionnaire en fait vous
répondez des probabilités
excusez-moi si c'était pas que c'était
pas car j'ai floride il expliqué l'idée
c'est un qcm bayésiens donc au lieu de
répondre oui ou non vous raconter si
vous êtes sûr que vous êtes sûr sur une
échelle de 0 à 10 et après le deuxième
lien bit ly corbeil s'est arrêtée un
lien avec lequel vous pouvez calculer le
score que vous avez en fonction de si la
réponse est vraie ou fausse et de la
probabilité que vous avez donnée point
sur le curseur qu'ils auraient misé sur
une échelle de 0 à 10 comme ça c'est
vrai aussi pour avoir ce que
le groupe l'ensemble de la communauté
ensemble et finalement qu'est la note de
vous tous heures ensemble en prenant la
moyenne de ce que vous avez dit en
regardant le score à social moyen donc
je viendrai à ça bientôt je vais d'abord
si c'est un peu plus sur le plan de la
présentation j'espère même temps c'est
la durée mais a priori ça va durer une
heure et demie on va dire quelque chose
comme ça peut-être plus nettement
c'est seulement plus mais bon on va
essayer de ne pas faire beaucoup plus et
on va parler un peu plus des thèses
groupe et après on va parler notamment
de un peu plus de l'été résultats de
tous young lee et revoir essayer
d'élaborer un peu ces résultats on va
les trouver un qui peut aussi et puis
ensuite on va essayer de voir ce qu'on
pouvait faire plus par exemple être plus
efficace si on a des tests à plus
d'étapes par exemple c'est d'analyser
tout ça plus petit à petit on va essayer
de prendre ensuite un peu plus de recul
et avoir une compréhension plus plus
fondamentale du problème des tests des
tests efficaces pour acquérir un maximum
d'informations en parlant notamment de
la théorie de l'information comment des
travaux de claude shannon et que comment
ils s'appliquent
comment est-ce qu'on peut les appliquer
ensuite pour améliorer
les tests et idées un peu fondamentale
ensuite on parlera du coup de revenir
draps l'algorithme de lit et on
essaierait de voir comment ça ne nous
éclaire sur sur ce que fait l'écho
rythme de l'hymne et ensuite on essaiera
d'aller plus loin en parlant
ce qui se passe dans des cas plus
généraux ou plus d'informations
probabiliste notamment sur les les
issues possibles et en parlant de plus
d'autres théories de l'information un
peu plus pendant des notions de
l'information conditionnelle et
d'information mutuelle et enfin on
parlera de conjecture de prendre pour la
nouvelle preuve de recharge passé les
chercheurs parmi vous mais je pense
qu'il ya quelques sujets qui en fait
mort je suis pas du tout un expert du
domaine or si ça se trouve tout ce dont
je vais parler ça existe déjà mais il me
semble qu'il ya une façon de modéliser
pas mal le problème actuel notamment si
on allait donner en plus du contact
racing pour pouvoir optimiser les tests
et savoir notamment à ce qu'on appelle
son appel des modèles deesing bon allez
c'est pour être permettre de
diagnostiquer plus avec moins de tests
ok ok on va passer aux résultats du coup
alors j'aurais dû développer un truc
pour prendre la moyenne je peux penser
quelque temps on peut voir toutes les
réponses
est ce que ça marche je vais parfait
voilà donc il ya eu 38 la réponse pour
l'instant
nantes petit à petit pioc et voyez que
vous n'êtes pas mal à avoir répondu
oui donc là qu'on se dit c'est travail
était un il ya une personne qui a
répondu zéro c'est à dire qu'elles
pensent que la bande annonce du coup et
il ya des gens incertain tout du long
j'ai pas de youtube pour calculer la
moyenne c'est bien fait
mais là pas moyenne ça c'est vrai qu'on
s'ennuie j'ai pas assez réfléchi bon
fait calcul est vite fait une moyenne
donc ça fait partir de vos réponses de
nice dont j'ai passé les trucs c'est toi
que c'est que ça avance en temps réel
est plus visible
par ailleurs si quelqu'un connait des
meilleurs outils pour pour faire ça
parce que je suis plus là la vôtre au
score nous votre prédiction moyenne à la
main c'est pas cool je suis tout à fait
preneur donc on me dit viser ça veut
dire par 45
donc la réponse moyenne à peu près à 7
et ça c'est cool parce que donc si vous
allez sur le deuxième nom revient donc
ce graphe donc ce sera un petit peu ça
donc là en fait en bleu là il ya le
score que l'on a si la réponse était
fausse
fêtez nom est en berne à la courbe
du score si la réponse était oui votre
moyenne était à peu près à cette donc sa
valeur de m
c'est à dire 8 7 6 10 8
ça ça veut dire que si répond c'est vrai
vous marquez plus seuls huit points +
8,4 points
et si la réponse est non vous marquez -
15 ponts on peut avoir des scores
négatifs
je vais vite et avoir des scores
négatifs et dans ce cas la réponse était
oui en fait c'est possible de l'union on
reviendra plus tard sur comment est ce
qu'on fait ça mais vous sachez que pour
l'instant la réponse est oui il est
possible de trouver la boule au labo
là-bas l'intruse balles retrouvées
samedi aucune la balle qui est l'intrus
avec seulement 2 peser donc la réponse
était oui
et du coup vous marquez collectivement 8
points 8 points sur 10 donc c'est
vraiment pas mal individuellement aussi
vous pouvez calculer le votre score on
regarde on bat fonction de la réponse
que vous avez donné le nombre de points
que vous marquez sas et c'est un obsédé
opus mba 10 ans donc j'ai parié sur ma
chaîne et l'application des apps que je
vais recommander
maintenant pays tirés web coin non
pestis web up
vous pouvez vous amuser à essayer de
répondre des réponses probabiliste en en
allant sur ce site web qui vous propose
des qcm
ok donc ça c'est très cool
ça marche pas
ok ok donc on va passer un peu plus au
coeur du problème qui est donc
aujourd'hui on va apparaît un peu plus
des tests groupe et ça sera un peu plus
précis et c'est de comprendre un peu
tout ça donc pour ça j'ai un super truc
qui s'appelle ce cas du cou qui est du
bois destiné donc le problème donc je
sais pas si vous avez tous vu ce qu'est
ce qu'on en a qui n'ont pas vu la vidéo
que les sorties hier soir jean qui en a
en tout cas guère sport j'ai 18 heures
donc j'ai mis une vidéo où j'expliquais
comment est-ce qu'on peut augmenter le
nombre de personnes dépistées sans
augmenter le nombre de tests en testant
de manière groupée
donc l'idée c'est que lorsqu'on collecte
des échantillons de différentes
personnes au lieu de 2 testés
individuellement chacun des tubes à
essai la collecte d'échantillons en fait
on va prélever un tout petit peu de
chaque de chaque tube à essai et on va
mettre ça dans un autre jeu tubes à
essai et on va mélanger tout ça et on va
tester ce mélange et si jamais le
résultat du mélange et
négatif c'est-à-dire paddock au vide
mais en retour les pinceaux entre
positif négatif ça pas de co vide
s'il n'y a pas de kovy dedans le mélange
ça implique qu'il n'y a pas de kovy de
nulle part
donc là le truc génial c'est que du coup
on peut permettre de garantir que 5 dans
ce cas cinq patients n'ont pas le coc
vide avec un seul test ce qui réduit
beaucoup le nombre de tests nécessaires
par par personne dépistée
dans le cas contraire si jamais il y a
sicilia co lead est bien là cette fois
ce qu'on va faire si on va faire des
tests individuels
voilà test individuel ce qui va nous
faire faire cinq tests en plus donc il y
avait un test collectif +5 ce test en
plus donc parfois on va faire plus de
tests que d'habitude mais l'espoir c'est
que en moyenne on en fera quand même
mois alors quand vous imaginez c'est pas
un truc ultra préparés que j'ai fait un
centre et qu'il a dit hier j'ai décidé
de faire le live ce matin test positif à
ces seigneurs présence de qu'ovide
positif cigale qu'ovide est négatif
c'est un peu perturbant je mange
toujours les pinceaux avec tout ça
surtout quand on pense à parler ensuite
de tests sérologiques ce concept
conte cuisine est négatif c'est pas de
colline
j'essaie de dire plutôt qu'aux vide ou
pas trop vite ce sera détectée ok ok
donc je vais pouvoir passer un deuxième
cuisent donc le 2ème cuisent cette fois
donc il va avoir lieu sur l'échangé un
truc du liant donc cs4 à elie live un +
2 et la question est la suivante 8
la question est la suivante on va se
poser maintenant que la probabilité
d'avoir que l'aco vide est très petit
on suppose que très peu de gens dans la
population on la copie de la question
c'est combien de tests seront
nécessaires à suffisant en gros un ordre
de grandeur pour tester tous les cas on
veut tester tous les cas on sait que ja
n personnes dans la population et il ya
paix une fraction play d'entre eux qui
ont la colline est ce que le nombre
total de tests qu'il faudra les saisir à
suffisant sera de l'ordre de haine x p
ou est ce que ce sera un peu plus que ça
est ce que ce sera moins que ça est ce
que l x p alors techniquement pour les
matheux parmi vous parce que mt est une
bonne
approximations sais ce que c'est bien le
équivalent une équipe n'est qu'il en
simple asymptotique est-ce que l'erreur
relative on va dire si j'estime avec nps
que l'erreur relative tant vers vers
zéro lorsque j'estime le nombre minimal
nécessaire et suffisante de tests par
une fois paie donc typiquement ça veut
dire que s'il ya une probabilité de 10
pour ce point là on va se poser paix
très petit mais supposons que la preuve
est d avoir le lac vite c'est un sur
mille
et il y à un milliard de personnes mondo
bizarro milliards pour ça qu'ils les
calculs et une personne sur mille à
halak vide est ce que ça veut dire que
l'on aux deux tests nécessaires sera de
l'ordre de 1 million parce qu'un million
cette bonne approximation du nombre de
tests nécessaires n c'est le nombre de
personnes potable dans la population et
pc en gros la fraction d'entre eux qui
ont accolé idée on va supposer que c'est
chacun à la copie de manière
aléatoire et indépendante des autres
donc dans le lit des indépendants
identiquement distribués voilà ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne
approximation quel est votre degré de
confiance entre 0 et et et 100% entre 0
et 10 à 10 si vous êtes sûr de vous 0
c'est que vous êtes sûr de vous mais que
la réponse est non donc je dis c'est sur
de nuke la réponse est oui
donc faites gaffe de mettre zéro ou 10
je vois que des gens qui ont mis 0 10
ans déjà que je connaître
voilà vous voyez un peu les réponses
vous êtes assez étalée en fait il ya
vingt-huit une réponse
ça part un peu un peu partout est ce
qu'une paix cette bonne approximation
est ce qu il en faudra plus c'est ce
qu'il faudra - sk une baisse une bonne
approximation comme qu'en pensez vous
c'est notre devoir c'est grâce à lui si
marre de voir qu'il ya peu du genre
autour de 2,5
de plus trois ou sept pencher d'un côté
ou de l'autre c'est intéressant
c'est très intéressant j'aime bien cette
animation de encore s'ils devaient votre
vivent encore quelques instants est ce
que une fois puis est une bonne
approximation
j'espère qu'à la fin la vidéo on verra
un peu plus en détail ce qui se passe
vraiment espérer la fin de la vidéo vous
comprendrez un peu plus cette question
et que ça deviendra un peu plus un
ce sont un peu plus instinctive pourra
vous dire ah ouais non ah ouais oui
c'est à peu près ça paquet
qui a dit que les attendre encore un
petit peu voir un petit peu le printemps
est toujours ce stress quand je fais un
truc l'impression de devoir parler fois
que je mate dans l'amérique fera que je
prends servi à musique la prochaine fois
je me suis un peu inspiré de fribourg
bornes pour ceux qui connaissent qui
commence a fait ça te faire ça je trouve
ça vraiment connu à le lien le lien il
monte le dire pour voter le lien donc
c'est sera bit.ly slash
elle y ce qui a beaucoup de vies
aujourd'hui vous parler d'un autre audi
s4 alive au q2 avec des tireurs dans ce
cadre un live avec 2 et voit les
prochains on se sera q3 q4 cuisse un
croissant que c'est comme ça
ouais ce qu'on est pas un peu influencé
en voyant la réponse des autres oui en
effet c'est ses remarques intéressantes
parce que dans le cas de fribourg bord
en fait il est la réponse était pas nos
mineurs qui nous voyaient s'il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui donnait la même
réponse me voyais pas quelle était cette
réponse et c'était assez intéressant
pour ça donc
heureusement je fais avec ce que je peux
j'ai même pas l'outil qu'avec les
utiliser
cris blues band ça c'est un peu dommage
voilà donc mon poids je vois aujourd'hui
faire un qcm composé des cinq questions
tout d'un coup là je voulais faire un
truc au fur et à mesure que les gens
regardent ce sera après ça permet d'être
plus petit à petit et puis comme ça ça
permettra de se concentrer sur un an un
qcm à la foire mais c'est vrai que sans
lui j'aurais pu faire je sais pas je
sais pas quelle qu'elles sont les
meilleures solutions et je fais avec les
moyens du bord mais c est des meilleurs
arrivent et je me suis tout à fait
preneur
toi tu ça y'est 5q cm2 une question
comme ça que ça va se passer
pour rappel le pnn c'est le nombre total
d'individus dans la population et pc la
probabilité qu'un individu de la
population et la copie de 19 ans suppose
que c'est tu pourras itp est la même
pour tout le monde dès qu'elle soit
indépendante rating c'est là la question
et pas forcément la plus simple à
comprendre
ouais c
fort c'est une équivalence et sa
sympathie pour ceux qui connaissent mais
c'est dire est-ce qu'on peut utiliser nt
comme une bonne approximation du nombre
de deux
deux tests qui seront nécessaires pour
diagnostiquer les ncn individus de la
population s'ils ont utilisé des tests
le groupe et optimaux ok ça serait bien
en fait qui la réponse en temps réel bon
je vais y aller au feeling ou via de
calculer exactement la moyenne de vos
réponses je suis allé au fini et j'ai
l'impression que la moyenne
vous vous contredisez vous ne compterez
dire s'il pensait que c'est à ça mais
impressionnant moyenne est entre 3 et 4
peut-être je pencherai plus sur quatre
je sais pas si ça vous voir on va
négocier on va dire que votre en moyenne
c'est 4 à la moyenne c'est 4
du coup je vais je vais clore ici on va
passer à la suivante vous pouvez de
façon continue et à répondre mais on va
se poser que moyenne que vous avez dit
que vous avez dit c'était 4 du coup on
peut voir le score que ça vous fait donc
est un régal quatre atomes si si la
réponse était oui c'est ouf et -4 points
sa réponse est non si vous fait trois
pour 3,6 points manquent à dire une cate
3,6 points il se trouve que la réponse
est non donc bravo encore une fois vous
pencher du bon côté prestations il y
avait commencé et est donc non donc l x
p c'est pas tout à fait la bonne
approximation
là encore on va mieux comprendre
pourquoi ces deux cas plus tard dans la
vidéo mais en fait on va voir petit à
petit je crois que
on peut en parler déjà de l'algorithme
de lits en particulier mais ce sera plus
clair quand on parlera de la théorie
d'information de notre pile et shannon
ok ok donc pour en revenir à ce que tu
veux qu'on va revenir ça et donc je vais
je vers décrire l'algorithme adoli alors
j'aurai décrire l'algorithme de lit donc
donc l'algorithme de lit c'est un
algorithme as et a donc donc à chaque
étape il y aura un paramètre qui va être
la taille des groupes testés donc
recommencer par étapes 1 étape 1 chaque
étape va se ressemblent et toute façon
l'étape 1 du coup ça va être une forme
des groupes de taille
carla
on forme des tailles de groupe tient et
on teste ses groupes ont testé
directement sûr sûr sûr qu'à un individu
à la fois et donc comme tu m'expliquer
situe ainsi pour chaque groupe groupe
positif quand c'est pas un groupe
négatif c'est pas de co vide de virus
ont détecté ne sortait pas pas
spécifique aux locaux vides ça ça veut
dire tous négatifs
donc à ce moment là tout le tout le
groupe est négatif et du coup tout le
groupe peut être renvoyés chez eux
peuvent circuler tout va bien mais si le
groupe est positif donc ça c'est virus
détectés
à ce moment là on va passer à l'étape 2
un cercle et les gens qui sont dans des
groupes positifs passent à l'étape 2 et
l'étape 2 bat en fait l'étape 2 c'est
très simple c'est la même chose si vous
avez compris ça
l'étape 1 b
tallandier nordi est en train de ramer
malheureusement du cru je suis galère un
peu restrictive
ouais
voilà bouclé l'étape 2 très pratique le
copier-coller puisque l'étape 2 avec la
même chose avec quelques petits
paramètres les changes puisque dans
l'étape 2
dans l'étape 2 cette fois on fait des
groupes de taille vous avez peut-être
deviné les groupes seront détail cette
fois k2 est ensuite ainsi de suite comme
qu'ensuite on à étapes trois avec qu'à
trois étapes 4 avec k 4 et 1 ci dessus
est donc ce moment on va s'arrêter à
l'étape finale qui va être l'étape
l'étape finale va être l'état peut jouer
après ça l'étape est ce moins en l'état
financera et capes
alors ce serait plus clair s'il appelait
les états ps
je gère pas encore très bientôt mis en
fait l'état paie sera un peu différente
puisque l'état paie ce sont les tests
individuels
plus
bon l'étape 4 waka 4,4 cannes jusqu'à
casser ks11 désolé c'est pas propre
ks moisan et on arrive ensuite à l'état
ps espère que c'est clair pour tout le
monde pas si c'était des questions c'est
mon déposé parce que c'est au moment où
vit le chat du mal à faire tout à la
fois donc ça c'est l'algorithme de lit
je maîtrise je maîtrise pomme bon c'est
el golpe de lille espère que
[Musique]
donc tant dans l'algorithme de lit on à
ces variables car un n folk sks moins un
qui sont les tailles des groupes à
chaque étape donc ensuite l'île du ski
ski à fès il a cherché à optimiser les
valeurs de 44 11 ans mais ce qu'il a
fait c'est qui en fait il a essayé
d'optimiser le pire cas donc le problème
comme comme on en a parlé en face il ya
pas de jolies formules pour le cas
probabiliste une certaine probité paix
pour chaque individu
donc le cadre qui a étudié lycée un
cadre un peu différent ce qui a fessé il
suppose qu'il y a on va me dire des
individus la paix fois nbc déterministe
on sait qu'il y en ad on sait qu'il n'ya
pas plus pas moins
je pose qui a des
patients positifs et donc la question de
l'iss et comment est ce qu'on fait pour
nous pour en faire pour optimiser le
pire cas c'est à dire être sûr qu'on
fera jamais trop de test
même si par malchance par exemple chacun
des patients positifs se retrouvent dans
des groupes différents et du coup il a
beaucoup de l'individu qui sont
négatives qui se font embarquer un peu
parlé positif à l'étape suivante
parce qu'ils étaient dans un groupe où
il ya un individu positif donc à ce
moment là donc on peut calculer donc le
nombre total de tests tout et vous avez
souhaité nombre de tests effectués dans
le pire cas non dans le pire cas alors
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le pire cas
alors dans le pire cas donc tu es donc
ça va être 61 plus t2 plus t3 et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à ts -1 et ts où tu étais
ici le nombre de tests à effectuer dans
le pire cas à l'étape du du de
l'algorithme de lits alors tu es un ça
va être combien 21 toxé avoir testé tout
le monde mais enfin pas tous les groupes
et donc i am / qu'à un groupe puisqu'il
coûte 2 car il ya un individu qui a
rédigé par kengo ensuite t2 orthez 2
dans le pire des cas tous les patients
positifs se trouvent dans des groupes
différents
et s'ils sont tous dans des groupes
différents ça veut dire que
le nombre d'individus qui passent au
second test sera tous les gens qui sont
dans un groupe d'individus positif donc
s'il ya des individus qui sont positifs
bon en fait il y en a partout leur
groupe
du coup ça fait des cas un individu qui
restent à l'étape 2 il reste dans pire
des cas il reste des cas un individu je
sais pas si c'est clair tu as et il ya
les des patients positifs qui embarque
tout leur groupe mais à l'étape 2 du
coup on voit cette fois on va tester des
groupes de taille k2 donc on prend tous
ces individus curation les les thèses
par groupes de taille k2 du coup ça fait
on va diviser par k2 en fait le nombre
des tests à faire puisqu'il ya des
demandes et caïn disait part qu'à deux
groupes formés à la deuxième étape alors
que c'est clair ensuite la troisième
étape cette fois il va rester dans le
pire des cas en fait sur les cas de
goulée il y aura encore des groupes qui
vont qui vont rester et cette fois c'est
des groupes de taille qu'à 2 ou dans le
pire qu'ait restera des cas deux groupes
enfin un individu qui se font embarquer
dans 3e 23e partie parce qu'ils sont
dans un groupe où il ya un individu
positif et cette fois adapté trop
étroits en fait des groupes de taille k3
donc me disait parc à trois et ainsi de
suite
et jusqu'au groupe à étapes est moins un
bas si vous voyez un peu ce qui se passe
en fait il y aura des cas s - 2 / k s
nous ont donc voilà dks -2 et encore les
des individus positive qui vont
embarquer cette fois quatre fois est
moins décalé ce point de personnes parce
qu'ils ont embarqué leur groupe à chaque
fois là elles se font en fait un test
sur quelqu'un mozart car enfin avec des
groupes de taille 4 11 ans ont disparu à
ce moulin et à la fin il faut tester
tout le monde tous les gens qui restent
donc tous les gens qui restent on a des
cas s mozart
il ya des individus infectés qui
embarque tout leur groupe
ok donc ça c'est le nom de tests à
effectuer dans l'algorithme de lit si on
fait des groupes de taille car un k2 k3
lesquels 111 ans ok donc si on veut
maintenant faire à l'idée de lire
ensuite c'est de minimiser 7,7
cette quantité
alors comment est ce qu'on fait pour
minimiser cette quantité
donc on va utiliser des outils d analyse
j'écoute pas trop rentrer dans tous les
détails ici
cuilhé ans à cette équation qui va être
l'équation importante c'est le nombre de
tests dans le pire klein et on peut
noter que le nombre de tests dans le
pire cas en tout cas pour les premiers
terre ne sera pas si différent surtout
si paix est faible du cac moyens puisque
en général les individus sont dans des
groupes différents donc c'est sur la fin
quand ce sera moins bonne approximation
du cac moyens donc pour pour maximiser
sa ce qu'on va regarder si les dérivés
de thé par rapport à chacune des
variables donc pour rappel donc y'a rien
théorème très simple qui dit que si elle
fait des rives à bhl et hic c est un
maximum alors f primes de x est égal à
zéro
c'est une vie du bon bah je bougeais pas
le justifier sur les calculs du coup ce
qu'on va regarder cette fois c'est donc
ccc les dérivés de thé je vais appeler
des cons un de tes donc ça ça va être
des de thé / des cars un dérivé du
nombre de tests parce que fait varier la
valeur de 15 cas du rouquin je regardais
aussi on va oublier l'histoire de
vraiment carrick à deux et tout ça ce
sont des nombres entiers n'ont aucun cas
plus générale donc des donc ça on se
rend compte que la plupart des termes
ici sont indépendants de carats en fait
est que ces termes là qui vont dépendre
d'aucun qu'en fait ça va être des sur
des cas entre de haine / k1 plus des cas
1 / k2 est donc mon la bombe à supposer
que vous savez dernier une fonction ça
me fait moins de 10 est parti un quart
est plus divisée arcade
tu peux aussi je regarde regarde
lorsque cette quantité est égal à zéro
ça ça va arriver si et seulement si - n
/ 15 au carré plus des / cadre légal à
zéro ce qui arrive si et seulement si
elles / carats au carré est égal à des /
k2 je me j'ai mis ça de côté
ensuite on va mettre x car un carillon
avec qu'un car de l'autre côté qu'à deux
côtés où ça me fait un cadeau idéal à
des cars au carré ça va être sinon
scission aussi parce que je vais faire
si je vais / n ça nous fait qu'à 2 égal
à t / n karakar et pourquoi ça ça
viendra ce parce que des / rennes on a
vu ça des / n bas ça nous fait p et
compétent dors meary nord dirhams comme
pas possible
voilà
donc ça c'est la première condition
plus je récapitule
[Musique]
on le dérange de thé qui gagnent 0,6 et
sur moi aussi j'ai oublié ce nicolas
résultat soit c'était cadeau est égal à
pékin car c'était acquis souvient de ne
pas être assez ne pas être assez bons
ensuite parce que je vais regarder c'est
pour les autres termes c'est un peu ça
fait des trucs qui se ressemblent donc
si je vais poser
j'y sois j appartenant 2 jusqu à s
pondeuses donc la dérive et de j on
parlera qu'agit de thé ça va être cette
fois des sur des cas j de voir un des
cas j - un / kg plus des cas j'ai
utilisé par cas j + 1 et
ça et donc ça si le dérive ça m'a fait
moins d cagim aux / kadji au carré plus
été utilisé qu'à dit plus haut du coup
qu'à des orgies d'hôtes est égal à zéro
si et seulement si bas en fait ce terme
jamais de l'autre côté donc ça me faire
des cas innocent / quasi carré est égal
t'es sûr qu'elle j + 1
la rouler les dés vont s'annuler cas j +
1 on va mettre d'autres côté kjk raid
autre côté ça nous fait qu'à gymnase un
cas j + 1 est égal à quasi carré je suis
me permet de réécrire en cas j + 1 il ya
qu'à gilles carrez casino et faut faire
gaffe à bien ça c'est ce qu'il faut pas
plus
ok et enfin il ya un dernier
ok ok et puis enfin il ya un dernier
point ses taux par rapport à 4 11 ans
donc des placements au sein de thé ça se
fait juste les deux derniers termes je
passais un peu et calcule rapidement
faire chez vous si vous voulez
mathématicien ou car plus tu es du coup
on a des aces - un de tes est égal à
zéro 6 sont ainsi qu'à la seconde carrés
qui gagnent la seconde
ouais et du coup voici je récapitule on
a été habitué tout fait on va voir
surtout
est on à ces trois relations
qu'ils nous donnent et du coup on peut
maintenant essayer de calcul est
différent terme qu'on sait déjà que k2
est égal et karakar essayé d'exprimer
tout en fonction de quatre ans
maintenant sur garde qu'à trois quatre
ans on peut appliquer cette formule donc
ça nous fait cadeau au carré fois qu'à
un pour ogier égale deux puissances
posant comme ça ça va être égal à pékin
au carré ou carrées regard menaçant
c'est égal ap carey car un os qu deux
fois de suite si on fait qu'à 4 cette
fois ça me faire 4-3 au carré cas de
besoin de toi avec cette formule ici et
donc ça ça va être égal ap car un quart
et non pécari pub
wakata un cadeau bouazza et à un regard
et sa fatigue et -1 et en fait ça va
durer trois heures à saborder
donc là on a un p carrés au carré ça
fait p puissance 4 là on a un paiement
1,83 popul et au niveau des quais rare
donc on a trois fois deux ça fait 6 - 2
ça fait 4 il s'est en fait car en
puissance 4 donc là on commence à
regarder avoir un peu une un pattern
peut-être c'est que c'est ça fait le
reste et pékin au carré puis un ep
careca inculpé au pub k1 puissance 4
donc en fait on peut voir que le peut
donc on peut faire une conjecture sur la
conjecture
c'est que je dis que ça serait un peu
plus scolaire est un peu moins vulgaire
rising d'habitude cela qu'on a déjà
versé que kg donc ça l'air de ressembler
à duper puissance j - ans qui a
impuissance
j alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
démontrer sa bat souvent on va démontrer
sa part récurrence adversaires d'être
les gardent donc
donc on va faire une démonstration par
récurrence donc pas récurrence
alors la récurrence folle à
l'initialisation et l'hérédité donc
l'initialisation mon peuple on peut
prendre qu'à 2 ou bien qu'à 2 est égal
ap fois car au carré donc ça c'est bon
l'initialisation ensuite pour l'hérédité
comment très pur calcul hérédité bas le
suc suppose on suppose que c'est vrai
jusqu'à j supposons si on veut et on va
aussi devoir supposer que c'est vrai
pour le cas avant de se poser aussi
qu'on a qu'à j -1
qui est égal de la gay comme pas
possible
allez courage tu peux le faire quasiment
à ses revenus c'est puissant j - 2 qui
appuient sens qu'après en puissance
gimont alors pour initialisation du coup
il ya en fait en faut 2 donc on peut
commencer avec 4,1 et k2 me cahen était
liée à la paix puissance 0 48 cent sain
et bon pour l'initialisation et
maintenant si on a ça dans la cas j + 1
qui est égale donc j'applique cette
équation là en tout cas pour j
paul pour sa sauce à vox à ce que ce
soit valable en fait que j + 1 sur
l'intérieur as pondeuses je vais
rajouter cette condition qui 6 2
ça va suffire un sas prod est toujours a
juste besoin de j ai enfin c'est pas
très rigoureux tout ça je fais ça et là
il faut se désole idéalement faudra aux
formes et tout ça dans un langage
présenté hier une bonne copie mais bon
on va faire actionnaires d'ubs or alive
and the jets utilisent cette équation la
réutilisent ici et cette fois je vais
remplacer kjk réer kadji moins un parent
leur valeur ici donc ça nous fait pipi
sens j
je me suis déjà en train de vie de j
moins 2,4 à l'impuissance de j x ensuite
donc il ya moins on va fort multiplié
les exposants par - a et c du gymnase 1
on utilise parmi eux un cp puissance de
manger qui a en puissance un mange donc
là si on regarde les exposants d'art n'a
dupé claude j - j ça fait du jld et puis
j ai du mot de plus de sa fusion c'est
bien pensance j et k 1 puissance dans la
du doji plus ça nous fait un plus de gym
en jce a fait un budget qui gît puissant
et ça c'est bien la même expression que
ça mais avec j + 1 la passe de chine et
donc la réalité je peux la poussée
jusqu'à ce que j plus à ce que cette
équation de la soie valable c'est
lorsque j étais gallas man 2 vous savez
bien c'est parce ont bien réagi
l'employeur est responsable ça c'est
cool
[Musique]
donc la conjecture s'est transformé en
théorème plus sa puissance d'elle car
c'est pas un grand théorème donc le lem
qu'on vient de prouver c'est que
pour tous j ça va aller même de 1
jusqu'à s points 2 on n'a qu'à j égal à
et puissance gimont cas impuissance j'y
vois là là est bientôt finie on aura
bientôt la prochaine crise
il explique à utiliser cette équation là
donc cette question là qu'on n'a pas
encore utilisé
qui dit que ks moins un quart est égal à
k s man 2 quand je perds le truc encore
est il cette équation de là qu'on n'a
pas utilisée aussi les docks ont attisé
ya deux ans et il ya la paix car un cari
l'option l'équipe y compris donc en
utilisant sa voix du coup que tu as
moins deux il ya du couac as moins un au
carré et donc c'est égal à alors qu elle
s moins un quart et on sait que ces
données par ça donc c'est égal et
puissance de gym aux saveurs s'est
également bien écrire qu'à exploser donc
c'est lorsque j'ai est égal à espoo
hasard donc ça fait p puissance est
moins en moins en moins de quarante
puissance s maison et ça au carré
donc c'est égal ap puissance 2 esme ont
quatre au k1 puissance deux exposants
man 2 est ce qui va nous permettre de
nous en sortir c'est que ça se dote
d'une façon de calculer
ks -2 ça
une autre façon de calculer charisme au
moins deux c'est qu'il nous est donné
par cette équation là nous dit je crois
quelque chose - 2 et - 3 2
donc si je combine ces deux choses là ça
me fait que donc cas
si je commins et de choses là ça m'a
fait du cou d'oie côté plus qu à s
puissance s puisque le deuxième nom de
vols sont annulés le s en reste 1 2 à
droite et niveau du p delajoux mètres
1-1 et nous paie donc là on as à ce
qu'il fasse en aller et là on a moins
quatre +36 nous fait moins un ca
et du coup on va cette équation de la
qui nous fait du coup caïn est égal à p
puissance moins un mois - est-ce moins
un sens un mois' s à la puissance 1 / s
et donc sa cp puissance 1 / s
- zain
en fait je vais même l'éclair un peu
différent je vais indifféremment je vais
écrire - 1 + 1 / s
ok tous ces calculs pour pouvoir en
arriver
simplement qu'à 1 est égal à p puissance
- 1 + 1 / s en fait un pli conserve
aussi que kadji va être égal a donc fait
puissance gymnase un poids qu'a fait
puissance - j j / s donc ça ça va est
égal à régis annule donc ça me fait
duper puissance - en plus j / s
on peut aussi à décrire sa gamme étendue
paix puissance - j -
ça
j'utilisais pas ok
ok donc 7 cm et en particulier ont ce
qu'on peut voir c'est que si parlant de
je regarde des cas des cas j sur des
capucins fait ça ça va être égal à des
fois oui
bonjour les fascine
en science et de formules par exemple
[Musique]
ça nous fait donc des fois et puissance
j - un cac en puissance j'ai visé par et
puissance j&j plus simples où ça me fait
du thé / p et toi car des fois car un ça
nous fait quoi cet effroi carence ne
fait p puissance 1 / s donc l'idée forte
et puissante - the series
voilà donc en fait chacun d'eux et terre
va être égal à ça si je fais n / cas par
cas un une / cas quand ça nous fait un /
et un nom 1 / s
une fois tard
et du coup ça ça nous fait du duel x p x
p puissance - 1 / s et à une fois paix
on a quelques pendant l'après midi si
c'est légal à des papiers puissance au
monde 1 / s en fait au final si si je
combine tout ça
donc
tu es en fait est optimale pour qu'agi
et il ya la paix puissance c'était moins
est ce moi j / s et du coup à ce moment
là il vaut et chacun et terme va être
égal à ce qu'on vient de calculer ce que
les dires des et - 1 / s il y as terme
donc ça fait 7 égal à sa théorie mal
parce que à ça et on a tété l'étoile qui
est égal à sd faut appeler puissance - 1
/ s et du coup maintenant ce qu'on peut
se dire c'est on va optimiser la valeur
de s voilà donc si on maximise
maintenant la valeur de s
tétouan maintenant et donc quand imad
une fête est minimal sur tout alors là
là encore des calculs qu'on pourra faire
dériver ça par rapport à s je vais tuer
souhaité les étapes de calcul pour cette
fois est ce qu'il faut c'est que s est
égal à l aine de 1 / p et à ce moment là
on a des étoiles qui va être égal à
[Musique]
ad
demain
si mes calculs
bon tu call et des calculs je refais pas
tous ici et du coup ça serait sdp
puissance moins assurée ce qui serait du
coup inférieurs à eux eu ou c'est aussi
la constante de l'air avant de voir
apparaître ici fois des fois elle n 2 1
/ p donc déjà on peut le remplacer par
des forêts nous ça nous fait eux
pnl n 2 1 / p et vous pour répondre à la
question donc l'approximation par pn
marche faible ça peut être un terme qui
va finir par être qui prend une certaine
valeur cessera jamais d'être à très
grand le gars rythme sans jamais très
vite vers l'infini mais ça fait un peu
plus que que pn nous plaît de
l'approximation c'est plus de l'ordre de
pn toilogue de 1 sur pied avec une
constante et ça a été une analyse du
pire cas mais on verra plus tard que en
fait le cas moyens et pas nous pas si
différent de simples ok ok donc la fait
pas mal de matches des gros calculs je
suis prêt quel moment de faire un autre
puise
euh ok sera peut-être plus au feeling
que que super un calcul parce que c'est
pas une question un peu difficile mais
le prochain puise
voilà donc ce supposons que maintenant
paix est égal à 0,1 donc celle à 10 %
la question c'est quel est le nombre
optimal
l'étape qu'il faut rythme de vie et en
particulier est ce que il vaut mieux pas
faire un algorithme à trois étapes donc
tant dans les vidéos j'avais présenté
d'algorithmes en trois étapes
donc c'était une question de mémoire
aussi ce que j'allais présenter la
section dans la vidéo est ce que vous
pensez qu'à ce moment là ce que de
mémoire peut-être l'algorithme à 3 et à
trois étapes c'était le meilleur rapport
à la tête de l'état ou peut-être que
également un album est un quatre étapes
seraient peut-être meilleur
qu'est ce que vous pensez
ok votre feeling
alors qu'à kehl de tibane d'état quel
est votre degré d'incertitude vis-à-vis
de cette question
et pour pour simplifier les calculs mais
je pense que la réponse est la même
là le supposer qu'on applique vraiment
la cote de lee dans ce sens où on prend
les valeurs indiquées par paris et
palais valeur optimale détail de coupes
même si c'est quasiment pareil ça change
pas grand chose est ce que un algorithme
trois étapes c'est la meilleure chose à
faire camper est égale à 10%
ou est-ce qu'il faut peut-être plus
d'étapes ou peut-être moment d'étape
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'était pas une bonne nouvelle ont cédé
dans les calculs aussi dû aussi aux
syllabes aurait dû laisser ses calculs
de côté faire plus et cuisent est ce
qu'un plus marrant les cuisines je
posais pensez quoi des calculs est ce
que vous avez trouvé ça un peu trop un
peu trop scolaire ou
qu'est ce que vous pensez
on me pose moi
ok j'ai fait une petite pause pipi ok il
ya moins de réponses senna qui sont
endormis après tous ces calculs
c'était peut-être pas malin de faire
autant de calcul
aia
et quelques faut laisser aux intéressés
des 10 titres vos amis on s'est fait ces
vidéos pour vous si vous pensez que
c'est bien que j'aurais pas dû les faire
dit que c'était un peu plus à bord et
pour moi aussi fait persécutent
ouais
c'est ça c'est du dior ses défenseurs de
la gueule j'ai eu 7 michael sont très
cool aussi ceux de fribourgeois n'ont
pas mal inspiré mathématiques
supérieures géologie laisser une
trivialité
j'ai même pas besoin de le démontrer
s'arrêter quelques brasses avis sera en
replay parce que ça c est parti parce
que la moyenne est à peu près autour de
5 ans il ya des avec 5 des réponses à
ces extrêmes aussi donc
donc la réponse est oui si je me trompe
pas tache mars qui ont plutôt bien je
crois que la réponse est oui une fois je
suis certain qu'en tout cas si vu qu'il
a répondu cinq buts marqués zéro prendre
mois marqués pas de points négatifs à
l'enseignante instant chaque fois
c'était c'était vous est-il dans le
positif à chaque fois dans le monde au
prince et qu on profite toujours du bon
côté
alors non c'est pas ça que je vous
montrez moi sinon je peux montrer sa
voix a donc ça c'est un peu les calculs
hésité à les refaire mais j'utilise un
intrus qui s'appelle desnos et desnos du
coup on s'est assez pratique pour faire
des grâces en plus on peut définir des
fonctions intégrées à utiliser ce qu'est
ce que ce qui est utile
donc là qu ici c'est la probabilité de
devoir passer aux tests suivants
souvenir donc il ya plusieurs étapes
q c'est un projet de devoir passer à
l'étape suivante
si on suppose que la probabilité p à ce
moment là qu'un individu tirer au hasard
soit positif c'est illégal ap est-ce
qu'on suppose qu'on a fait des groupes
de cas bon courage aux gens et j'avais
parlé dans la vidéo mais une boucle à la
probabilité que du coup on soit dans un
groupe positif et c'est un mois en moins
pétillant ce cas c'est l'inversé le
complément de 1 - p puissant sky qui
après vérité que tout le monde soit
négatif dans le groupe
et du coup si on fait un test à deux
étapes le nombre de tests qu'il faudra
faire en moyenne sept fois je suis en
moyenne pendant pas dans le pire cas ça
va être un sur cas plus
donc 1 / cas c'est donc au moyen de
tests
pour par individu dans un groupe de
taille car c'en est un il ya un test
pour tous en moyenne ya un sur qui
atteste par individu et si on sait les
tests individuels donc pu du pk donc ça
toutes affichaient donc ça c'est cette
courbe l'accès à cette courbe eu là
c'est le en fonction de la valeur de
paix si j'applique l'algorithme de lit
avec des tailles de groupes de paix
puissance - 1/2 donc en sus racine
carrée de paix servent alors qu'on vient
de calculer à ce moment là la courbe
ressemble à ça si on regarde un test à
trois étapes un peu le test à trois
étapes
donc soit on finit tout de suite avec un
groupe de taille car donc c'est un jeu
ça fait 1 sur 40 est à un individu ou
sinon on doit passer à l'étape suivante
et si on passe à l'étape suivante donc
avec une probité q2 et 40 à ce moment là
la petite subtilité c'est que parmi les
gens qui sont déjà passés la probabilité
qu'ils aient le coc vide à co-lead a été
cette fois / la probabilité d'être passé
test suivante donc ça c'est une formule
de beille ce qui est cliquée derrière ça
ouais je suis pas le démontrer ici et du
coup ça change un petit peu ça mais
sinon c'est nous ramène aux fêtes aux
cas précédents où la probabilité d'avoir
la corrida a augmenté a été multiplié
par 1 / q2 pays de carn et à ce moment
là la performance donc le nom de camp
donc c'est nombre de personnes qu'on
peut soigner par test que c'est un
surnom de test un individu ça va être
cette quantité avec des tailles de
groupe
comme ce qu'on vient de calculer et donc
si on regarde cette courbe et là on se
rend compte que pour 10 % 10 % ses 6,1
la courbe orange fait mieux que la
courbe verte donc avec trois tests ont
fait mieux qu'avec de test si on passe à
4 donc je suis même équation 2 6 4
si on passe à quatre cette fois bon en
fait avec 10 % 3 3 étapes restent mieux
donc il faut vraiment descendre à 0,06 à
0,05 cent soixante quinze pour que
quatre étapes deviennent meilleurs que
trois étapes et il y avait quelqu'un
dans le iv qui avait signalé c'est que
en fait on avait été bien calculée je
vous ai dit que la tête que le nombre
d'étapes optimal étaient
écrire ici le texte
la taille optimale c'était est égal à
peu près égal à loeb de 1 / p donc si on
veut mais était paix est égal à un
dizième ça nous fait l aine de 10 qui
est égal à 2,3 donc il y avait quand
même moyen d'hésiter entre 2 et 3
c'était quelque chose entre 2 et 3 il y
avait moins de visites est donc là ce
moment là très bien peut compter sur
peut-être sur sa mémoire où je faisais
pas le temps de faire ses calculs
j'aurais pas eu le temps de faire ses
calculs on live booth était normal et
résidences et c'est bien d'avoir montré
votre hésitation
et puis on peut monter fait pour 5 pour
six façons plus la probabilité est
faible plus on a intérêt à faire
beaucoup d'étapes conformément ellender
1 surpris qu'on vient de voir et à un
truc intéressant qu'on peut noter c'est
donc dans l'absolu qu'il est le nombre
optimal de qu'on pourrait imaginer
si on avait des tests pour vraiment aux
petits mots qui vont chercher son talent
trop vite shannon voilà donc la courbe
violates s'adonne borne supérieure
surtout ce qui atténue abl alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a cette borne là
ça vient pas de nulle part
et ça vient d'eux et je vais en parler
maintenant on va entrer dans merveilleux
monde de la théorie de l'information
on va parler de la théorie de
l'information qui est vraiment un bijou
c'est vraiment des trucs ça et c'est un
truc qui a été inventé par un mec qui
s'appelle claude shannon et on dit
souvent que les découvertes
scientifiques sont sur le produit du
travail collaboratif de beaucoup de
personnes et a tendance à beaucoup de
casse et si on est collé vrai mais dans
le cas de la tohu d'information il ya
vraiment un mec qui a fait dix mille
fois plus que n'importe quelle autre
c'est claude shannon coach hans et c'est
vraiment vrai qu'un incroyable
[Musique]
ouais je sais pas si j'en ai déjà parlé
dans une vidéo s'annonce folle j'ai un
peu monde ça si c'est si c'est pas
encore le cas je viens sans doute encore
en parler notamment celles sur belle
lorsqu'on y reviendra mais que claude
shannon c'est vraiment un mec formidable
ça déjà c'est un mec cool
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas dans
l'histoire des mathématiques
john nash par exemple été un peu plus
alors on va dire les coaches a été
vraiment un mec très très cool très très
sympa et
et en 1948 il a vraiment bouleversé
notre compréhension de ce qui est
l'information en particulier
donc c'est un peu un contemporain c'est
carrément un contemporain de d'alan
turing ils se sont rencontrés pendant
une guerre mondiale donc c'est aller les
idées avec la nature n y étais sont
quand même un peu lié il ya des liens
assez forts entre eto'o et d'information
de shannon et présente les curseurs de
crédence de turing est aussi une machine
de turing du tout seul et à ses proches
et a crû de shannon a affiché une
information donc sans doute en partie en
réfléchissant à la cryptographie
c'est cette époque là il y avait des
chiffres avec la machine enigma des
codes nazis et tout ça est ce que vous
avez vu le film
imiter schengen maintien qui en parlent
souvent bien des fois on parle et le
canon kpama l'affiché à ça il a réfléchi
à ce qui était un chiffrement optimale
chiffrement de shannon avec des clés
symétriquement pas entrer dans les
détails de sa qui brûlent vraiment
l'information essayé très bien très très
lié à l'infanterie d'information est là
également réfléchi à qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que communiquer de
l'information
pourquoi est-ce qu'on utilise des
lettres pour communiquer cette
information parce qu'il ya des langages
qui sont plus optimaux que d'autres pour
communiquer de l'information tous à
allier vraiment et merveilleuse ont
expliqué par la théorie de l'information
donc il ya un article de 1948 si vous
êtes un petit peu matin il n'y a pas
besoin d'être ultra matin c'est un
article très technique mais faut quand
même s'accrocher un peu mais si bas si
vous êtes un peu matheux je vous
conseille vivement la lecture de cet
article
à titre individuel il se trouve que
c'est le premier article historique on
va dire que j'ai lu jusque là je lui je
lisais pas soit des cours soit des
articles récents et ce après un peuple
me suis plongé dans un article original
et ça vaut largement son pesant de
cacahuètes
façon ce qu'on peut parler de pesant de
cacahuètes pour un article scientifique
surtout s'ils payaient plus tôt à
retraduire de la formation en trio g et
vous fait pas coutume la casse est
vraiment l'article fabuleux qui explique
par exemple des trucs assez assez tôt
rob pourquoi est ce que par exemple les
plus facile d'inventer des mots croisés
en anglais qu'en français
ben en fait il une explication qui vient
directement de la théorie de
l'information et en particulier de
l'entropie de shannon des différents
langages
ça s'appelle que quelqu'un demande son
article je pouvais le titre parker au
sein de ces articles s'appelle le matin
michael curry communication ça a été
publiée dans bell bell labs ya un livre
aussi sur la ville de shannon et en
films aussi un documentaire
je crois qu'ils s'appellent beatplayer
maintenant on voit il faudrait chercher
show de shannon c'est surtout ma mémoire
est moins fiable
ok alors qu'elle est de shannon a lors
de ces moments où je vais revenir aux
premiers à la première énigme donc pour
rappel la première énigme que vous avez
posé
donc tu la première ni que vous allez
poser c'est c'était parmi quatre boules
l'une est différente soit plus hors de
soi plus légère donc je vais résoudre ce
problème et après je vais voir 10
expliqué qu'est-ce que ça avoir appuyé
la théorie des informations donc voilà
donc pour rappeler le problème donc on a
quatre boules c'est qu'une est
différente peut-être qu'elle plus
lourdes séquelles plus légère mais on ne
sait pas et ouais donc pas pour trouver
l'article de shannon suffit de taper
marie-clotilde communication sur sur
google ça sortira veut rajouter pdf pour
être sûr mais ça sortira c'est pas mal
de chercheurs qui ont mis sur leur page
perso donc donc par michael ball on sait
qu'on a une qui est plus légère ou une
qui est plus lourde et on dispose d'une
balance comparative on peut plus
comparer à savoir est ce que notre
équipe le groupe léger les questions et
crs que de deux peser suffiront pour
savoir quel boulet différentes et la
réponse est oui on peut savoir avec deux
peser de peser suffiront alors pourquoi
mon lit desmons voix supposer qu'on a
quatre boules donc je vais noté bull 1 2
3 4
très original et l'idée c'est qu'on va
commencer par une pesée un versus deux
jeunes étaient ça comme ça va commencer
donc pas un versus 2 et on met la
bouilloire à la poule 2 et il ya trois
issues possibles
donc il ya trois issues possibles soit
soit ça penche du côté de a
j'ai noté ça comme ça
je continue ça ouais ouais un plan que
2,6 alors que deux chronos je vous sais
pas symétriques un plus petit que deux
donc un plus petit que deux c'est à dire
que ça penche du côté de 2,5 soit 1 et 2
on le veut le même poids
je vais mettre un triplé galles pour
éviter d'écrire un égal 2 quelque part
ça fait toujours mal
soit il est plus grand et plus lourd que
deux on sait aussi ça la fout mal quand
on va souvent utilisée sans voix un peu
donc et dans tous les cas en fait son
affaire soit on le deuxième
'j'aime peser coin faire ça être un
versus 3
et lorsqu'on fait un versus 3 bat il ya
[Musique]
notre couleur il ya priori il ya trois
issues possibles je vais être un peu
bête et méchant poinçon qui sont du même
ordre d'idées donc et ainsi de suite
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut déduire
chaque fois donc à chaque fois ici ce
qu'on peut déduire c'est donc ils
risquaient en versus 3 6 6 1 et plus
légère que 2 est elle plus légère que 3
bat forcément celle intrus parce que si
c'est donc si on sait que par ceux des
six 6 6 1 et 2 n'ont pas le même poids
c'est à dire que 1 ou 2 et l'intrus et 6
6 2 et est l'intrus alors 1 et 3
devraient avoir le même poids du coût
devrait tomber dans le trou dans la cire
et plus plaisir que trois lorrains lien
est l'intrus et on va dire je vais
mettre un mois pour dire que l'intrus et
elle est plus légère
6 sinon ici donc c'est son avis ici
c'est un de plus hilare que 6,1 et plus
elle même poids que trois c'est à dire
que 1 et 3 a faites sont toutes les deux
des balles normales des boules normal du
coup c'est forcément de et c'est comme
comme un été plus cher que de faire
peser plus lourd si maintenant 1 et plus
légère que 2 et 1 est plus lourde que
trois places elle s'est imposée parce
qu'on a du coup 1 2 et 3 parce que là
forcément du coup 3 et plus légère que
deux ou trois y ait plusieurs cures en
relais plusieurs 2 c'est à dire qu on a
du coup 3 qui est pas différent de 2 et
qui a aussi deux policiers en dehors
donc forcément donc là c'est quelque
chose d'impossible puisque on aurait
trois boules de poids différents alors
qu'on sait que via une seule couleur
intrus qui est qu'il un truc là là si on
est de la cie à un point que deux du
classement on sait que trois ou quatre
et l'intrus et look 6 6 1 et plus légère
que trois c'est à dire que 3 est pas la
même que 1 et 2 alors que les deux ans
sont sous l'égide ne sont pas d'intrus
donc là forcément 3 et l'intrus et 3 et
d'un truc à ce que 1 vous me dire que
c'est presque un plus en plus cher + 3 3
donc si un et plus légère que trois
c'est à dire que trois en fait la plus
lourde qu à l inverse ça serait 3 qui
serait plus légère maintenant l'autre
truc ici c'est que si le même poids que
2 et 1 à une époque les trois gains et 2
et 3 ont le même poids donc forcément
catherine intrusion sais pas s'il est
plus lourd aux plus légers 7 4 mois ou
quatre plus donc on sait pas si quatre
et plus légère plus au delà on sait que
c'est un truc donc ça nous suffit hélas
non par symétrie parfaite ce cas là et
si je m'abuse impossible puisque là on
est trois plus hauts records qui a pour
quatre ans que deux ça ça serait de moi
et ça ça serait un plus ok donc c'est
donc ça prouve que l'on peut
ça c'est une solution en fait par un et
deux quarts temps comparé à 1 3 et après
on fait l'analyse et on sait moins c'est
forcément si dans laquelle déboulé et
plus lourds eux non alors pourquoi
est-ce que c'est intéressant d'un point
de vue de la théorie de l'information
d'apprendre la théorie de l'information
tout d'abord réfléchir au nombre de cas
originalement possible donc la théorie
de l'information va pas permettre de
résoudre ça mais ça permet de mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe donc je
m'étais oméga l'ensemble des possibles
est en fait l'ensemble des possibles ici
c'est soit on avait un mois soit on
avait un plus ce qu'on avait deux mois
on avait de plus si on avait trois mois
si on avait trois plus j'en ai quatre
mois se font avec 4 plus et est donc ça
ça veut dire que le nombre de possibles
ici gallant fait à 8
il y avait huit cas originaux
originalement possible donc lorsqu'on a
un ensemble comme ça on peut associer
une incertitude une entropie donc ça
c'est ce qui a été fait par boltzmann
avant de bien avant shannon shannon
c'est en 1948 boltzmann c'était vers
1870 signes ne trompent pas et bonne
semaine a défini l'entropie bon français
est un atout de physiciens mais si je
rate à la pâte
un peu boltzmann la définit l'entropie
des oméga comme étant trouve appelez le
log en base 2 du cardinal de omega donc
ce n'est pas exactement ça qui a défini
boatman jeu contre lui interprète à la
manière de shannon pas non plus tout à
fait ce qu'avait shannon mai
l'entropie qu'on peut associer un
ensemble c'est le logarithme en baisse 2
de son cardinal donc ici le logarithme
base de ckoi c'est c'est le nombre tel
que lorsque je mets donc ça c'est je
vais appeler à cette c1 nombre ch
d'oméga ici tel que c'est parce que je
peux faire ce que je sais que deux
puissances h2o média je suis mes deux
puissances a été gardien de mes gars y
est égal à 8
et là on se rend compte que h2o mega est
égal à trois puisque deux puissances 3
est égal à 1 8 donc c'est à dire quoi ça
veut dire que le nombre de de bombrun
impressionnant on dirait que le nombre
de bits d'information
le nombre de morceaux d'information
élémentaire peut être égal à 3 pour
pouvoir voir toute l'information sur
oméga ça cesse
oui on verra des bémols à remettre tout
ça plus tard mais ça c'est un peu l'idée
de quantifier d'incertitude on peut
avoir
bon tant pis
d'applications drame tant pis c'est pas
très bon
ok et en fait cette entropie la de
shannon enfin ce que j'interprète en
termes de shannan ça correspond une
entropie york que je suppose que tous
les cadeaux oméga sont aussi probable
les uns que les autres
donc en fait techniquement faudrait
parler de hache de la distribution
uniforme sur aux médias tous les cas
sont aussi probable comme on le verra
dans le cas des test groupe et c'est pas
le cas de toutes les configurations tous
les gens sont malades ne sont pas aussi
probable mais là dans ce cas on va
supposer que c'est le cas et à ce moment
là chaque chaque chaque test ici chaque
issue du test va nous permettre
d'acquérir un morceau d'information donc
ici lorsque je dis donc là si je voulais
vraiment savoir une fille née toute
l'information
il faudra un test final ici avec un test
final la jeu pour acquérir toute
l'information qu'il faut dans cela va
intéresser ici c'est de voir quelle est
l'information que j'obtiens à chaque
test je vais passer quelques trucs non
ok
et lille et de shannon c'est que
l'information d'un test tout cas à
postériori se rallier à quel point
c'était improbable l'intuition de chaîne
c'est que si si quelque chose est très
improbable
c'est que ça correspond à beaucoup
d'informations parce qu'il faut beaucoup
d'informations pour décrire ce cette
chose incroyable
si c'est un truc qui arrive tous les
jours en fait on n'a même pas besoin de
l'écrire parce que c'est ce qui arrive
c'est un peu l'intuition derrière c'est
plus profond que ça mais c'est simple
intuition derrière du coup pour
comprendre l'information d'un test pour
proférer c'est très important de voir
quelle est la probabilité des
différentes issues possibles du test
donc là si on reprend notre notre dans
notre cas lorsqu'on compare la boule à
la boule deux la question importante en
termes d'information acquise au moment
de tester un versus 2 une question
importante c'est de savoir quelles sont
les probabilités des différents tissus
dans quelle est la probabilité que je
tombe sur cette branche là d'après
quelques et cette probabilité là et bien
cette probabilité là c'est la
probabilité
enfin pour que ça ça arrive pour que un
message dans ce sens
en fait il faut soit un mois soit de
plus pour qu'un soit plus légère que
deux faut forcément qu'un soit plus cher
que les autres soient que deux fois plus
lourde que tous nous ça correspond à
deux cas parmi 8
il y avait lui qu'à originaux du coup
donc ces deux sur huit est égal un car
de la même façon un dans cette branche
là et il ya deux cas donc en fait ça
s'est également 2 sur 8 qui était
galerie car dans le cas du milieu
en fait on aura une et qu'un équilibre
entre 1 et 2
si et seulement si en fait tenir un ni
deux ni l'intrus s'essuie 3 et 4 sont un
truc ça ça arrive avec une chance sur
deux on peut y arriver aussi en comptant
le nombre d'issues 4 donc ça c'est
intéressant parce que ça me dit que il y
avait quand même pas mal d'incertitudes
sur les six du test 1k 1/2 ringard ça
nous donne beaucoup d'informations
donc on peut appeler h
donc ça je vais appeler ça le premier
test le t1 t1 c'est le premier test t2c
le deuxième test est bien ce qu'on peut
voir c'est que l'entropie de terrain
l'information que permet d'avoir le test
clients savaient également c'est à
l'entropie et ben en fait c'est une
fonction de tout ça et l'idée de faire
un juge d'ordonner la formule donc ça va
être un cas fois l'information que l'on
a si on part dans cette branche là et
cette information de la chaîne va
définir sa comme le log en base de
drakkar pourquoi
plus justifiée de différentes manières
mais bon il faut que ça marche mais pas
trop traîner un résultat juste prendre
ça pour acquis
donc ça c'est pr la première voire
ensuite la deuxième branche la 1/2 log
en baisse de 1,2 me et à dernière
branche un car logue pas de 2h15 alors
tu là ça se calcule bien du sens que ça
se calme plus bien donc c'est un quart
voit le log
alors partagé bien qu'elle ait un
problème c'est le log assure la
probabilité
donc en fait c'est un sur un car c'est
lui loeb en baisse de 2,4 +1 demie de
loeb en base 2,2 plus en cas log baisse
de 1,4
tout ça donc c'est égal à donc log en
baisse de 4,2 puissance combien était
guéri 4c 2 c'est un cloud 2 + 1/2
l'angop baisse de 2,2 puissance combien
est égal à 2 c'est un plus
ricard x 2 bon en fait ça fait 1,5 alors
c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire que la
première étape nous permet d'avoir un 5
bits d'information sur l'état de
suppression on sait certes c'est 1,5 but
de l'information et ça nous renseigne en
particulier sur eux sur oméga pour
connaître exactement un élément d oméga
il faut au moins trois bits
d'information un peu le message de de
shannon
donc on a fait un peu la moitié pour
arriver jusqu à courmayeur donc ça c'est
bien fait le problème c'est que ce sera
insuffisant parce que si on se regarde
dans cette branche là dans cette branche
là il n'y a plus que deux issues
possibles
donc quelle que soit l'issue du test au
mieux des cas il ya que deux issues
possibles
et du coup c'est ce qu'on appelle donc h
du 2 t2 si on sait que le résultat de
terrain si on sait que ça c'était six
ans et plus j'ai que deux si on se place
dans cette branche là conditionnement en
fait qu'on soit dans la branche de
gauche l'information de t2 basset opus
le log base 2 du nombre de cas possibles
ou mega
sachant que un petit que deux or ça
c'est égal au nombre de cas possibles
race plus que 2 c log en baisse de 2,2
donc ça c'est égal à 1 bis d'information
si on suit cette branche la fête on
gagne qu'un seul bit d'information
pareil sur cette branche là on gagne un
seul bit d'information
et maintenant quand on est sur cette
branche là bas et on va forcément
bloquer un petit peu quelque part et on
va gagner plus de bigorre formation mais
ça ne suffira pas à compenser le peu de
bide informations qu'on a gagné de
l'autre côté pour qu'en moyenne on y
arrive avec 3 3 étapes n'arrive à
acquérir trois bits d'information en
deux étapes
voilà donc c'est juste une petite
analyse que je fais tu ici de 2,2 ce
problème avec le nombre d'informations à
qui nos informations acquises avec et
avec une analyse comme sa jeune carrière
notre quizz de prévu cuisse times ok
ok voir ça a réveillé un petit peu
maintenant enfin ces petites
explications
donc si on joue on regarde le jeu du
juste prix
donc le jeu du juste prix finalement
c'est un jeu un peu similaire où on va
tester des choses donc le jeu du juste
prix c'est yahia il ya un présentateur
qui choisit un nombre va se poser que
faisait un nombre entre 1 et 1 million
et à savoir combien nombril réponse soit
oui c'est le juste prix soit plus petit
en fait le nombre est plus petit soit
plus grand donc la question vous pose
assez mais j'ai donc tout juste prix
il faut deviner un nombre entre 1 et 1
million avec une stratégie optimale
nous on est garantie de trouver le bon
nombre qu'est ce que vous pensez que
c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
donc pour être moindre comme tout et je
veux vous alors vous avez sur ceux ci
c'est pas grave et pouvait répondre
donc si vous répondait plus à droite
vous disent c'est que vous êtes sur la
réponse est oui
et si vous ne répondez tout à gauche et
que vous êtes sûr que la réponse est non
juste prix il faut deviner en oeuvre
entre 1 et 1 million avec une stratégie
optimale
on est garantie de trouver le bon nombre
après vingt essais 90e et celle 20e
nombre que vous dites
cette garantie que trente acteurs
répondent oui c'est le nombre
alors la réponse n'est pas 42
je vois juste prix chaque fois vous
dites en rond et vous avez le droit de
dire vraiment il faut qu'on maintienne
le l'animateur et les répondre oui
qui sont d'arthur sur robert wayne
robert voici les salaires d'être la
solution donc robert qui serait une
alternative à dp 3 t ce refrain d'avoir
un jour d'hui mais bon je récupère ma
question donc robert qui serait une
alternative à des pétro t donc robert le
donc suffi à jay robert est très
intéressant il a d'écriture intéressant
mais il ya aussi des limitations en
termes de fonctions saint-amand et je
suis très ambivalents villa vis-à-vis de
robert en temps je pense que quand tu as
créé signe très important même si jamais
le gouvernement français et des
autorités françaises l'inera il servait
tout ça continue on persévère et pense
qu'il faut y aller avec avec robert il
n'y soit aussi avec apple faut qu'apple
autorise un futur sur les chemins de sa
voisine sicilia mais ça va ce robert ben
oui je ferai une vidéo sur robert je
pense qu'il y encore un peu
d'incertitude
si je préfère attendre la
or je vois ont juste pris que 7 240 à
regarder maintenant il ya 46 ans il
pense même que c'est une question qui a
priori assez abordable même si vous
n'êtes pas sûr n'hésitez pas à répondre
que vous n'êtes pas sûr sur une échelle
de 0 à 10 à quelqu'un vous êtes sûr non
on n'a pas le droit à un million dès
cette semaine ce serait vachement plus
simple en effet ce que je ferai une
vidéo sur l'hypothèse de riemann si
c'est vraiment pas prévu ni dans un
avenir proche ni dans un avenir lointain
on prenait sera passé à cinquante
réponse est dévoilée est ce que
répondait
ok passé les 50 réponses donc voilà
voilà ce que vous avez répondu
donc vous êtes beaucoup à avoir dit oui
pour la moitié d'entre eux ont dit oui
prix y en a d'autres plus incertain jeu
je pense qu'un moyen net à neuf veux
dire c'est raisonnable alors 9 j'ai pas
fait le jeu 103 et essaie t à 4 donc
pour l'instant sur les scores vous avez
un coup hausse atteint 8 cd 8,4 plus 3,6
en france avec lui quatre +0 2 point ce
temps vous êtes à
[Musique]
12 hélas est très confiante donc soit
vous allez passer à 22 soit réalisée
pendant vingt dix alors pour moi vous
faire le calcul
oh alors donc vous hésitez entre les
noms peuvent être entre a et il ya et en
millions de dirhams comme pas possible
passé
vous hésitez entre un et 1 million et du
coup il ya un million de moins
un million de noms entre 1 et 1 million
et du coup que l'entropie htc oméga
haschke oméga est égal à donc le log
l'embase 2 2 1 millions et ça si on
regarde ça nous fait
je trouve des façons on peut faire un
énorme dit la prochaine fois je peux
comprendre les autres je me fais 19,9
voir ça ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire
que bout devant et c'est normalement
vous êtes sûr de lui qu'est le nombre
d'ouvriers de dire l'entropie d'un essai
donc donc à chu de maintenant imaginons
que
depuis
imaginons que vous hésitiez entre entre
a et b on va prendre un avocat
l'esa aux médias prime où il ya visité
entre des mondes entre a et b & b - on
va dire par la caisse
j'hésitais entre réel et vous faites un
test d'un nombre p les cas des cas c'est
le pari car on va dire à l'issue de ça
il ya dix à trois issues possibles soit
vous dis moi si on vous dit plus on vous
dit oui du coup l'entropie du test donc
le moins va arriver avec une probabilité
donc c'est ça va arriver pour les cas
moins un premier c'est qu'à moins d'un
sur aisne le plus va être le cas plus 1
/ n est le moins ses qualités pareil
donc donc l'entropie de tels cas ça va
être qu'à moins un sur aisne log en base
2 donc de 1 / cette probabilité donc ce
que vous faites n / qu'à monza alors
prendre ça c'est un jury
plus d'un sur aisne log en base de haine
plus capucins non pas fatiguée elle -
capucins suresnes noble base 2 de nvidia
sur elle
ok alors maintenant celui imaginons que
vous voulez trouver avec le moins de 2
paraît possible en fait il faut essayer
de maximiser cette entropie il se trouve
que cette entropie est maximisée je
crois que je peux tracé ça donc vous
voyez ignorer union veigneau ray pour
faire simple la réponse au milieu on
l'ignoré pour l'instant
et donc nous qui on l'appelle c'est à
peu près il ya surtout sip et les grands
ap log en base 2 1 sur p + 1 - p log en
baisse de 2,1 sur un an mais en
supposant que péter galles à cassure et
ça peut l'approximation
et donc si je trace le gras donc j'ai
appelé ça hdpc l'entropie or ce qui n'a
pas été et égale à pkp fois le banc base
2 et 1 / p
j'obtiens cette courbe là et donc ça
c'est l'autre au pis lorsque vous faites
un test qui a deux issues possibles et
la probabilité d'une issue est égale ap
ap réalité de l'autre et suez est il ya
l'a inventé et vous voyez que cette ceci
est maximisée lorsque la praille et tp
est égal à 1,2 me 0,5 nez qui démange
malkovich avec bret est donc en fait on
se rend compte que ce qui va maximiser
l'entropie ça va être de jouer au milieu
donc c'est la bonne approche
dichotomique donc comme certains l'ont
dit non pour répondre à qui veut taoufik
c'est le premier live que je fais de la
sorte je pense que je peux le prouver à
perdre et donc ses doigts de répondre au
milieu et on voit que si on répond au
milieu
[Musique]
h2 t -n divisé par deux si je sais
approche dichotomie je tire pile au
milieu
en fait ça va être on a une chance sur
deux de passer par là on va dire une
chance sur deux par la c1 2000 aux
gambas de 2-2-2 + 1/2 ohlen le combat ce
gain de 2 et ça c'est égal log en base
de ces gars là un salaire de 1000
puissante de nuit c'est égal notre copie
d'un test avec deux issues possibles et
forcément opus ces gars-là est égal à 1
lorsque c'est parfaitement dichotomique
parce qu'on divise ensemble des
possibilités par deux donc nous donne
dans ce cas en fait il une autre issue
possible qu'ils aient le oui ici en fait
on va faire le calcul mais parce que
nokia
ouais donc ça serait un sur aisne alors
adapté cette fois ça c'est
approximativement égale si je regarde
vraiment sa valeur donc il ya on va dire
une probabilité 1 sur elle bonjour je
fais quelques longs l'aï pas préparé à
voir ça et sinon opus on sait que c'est
notre pays va être au plus un demi pain
sur rennes
pour deux côtés lobs en base 2 sur un
deuil ou 1 sur rennes
pas très beau bon pas bon on va
concerner le cas simplifiée du nom ça
marche pas très bien si on va considérer
le cas simplifiée du juste prix ou
pendant les listes neuf premiers coups
on répond juste plus petits ou plus
grands et le dernier coup je suis le
change les règles en cours de cours de
près mais sans les calculs sont sur un
peu trop moche et dernier coup à le 20e
chrono biais de données en nombre et
soit on gagne soit on perd en dix ans ce
nombre à ce moment-là chèque
échec chaque nouveau guest que l'on fait
à une entropie 2-1 et en fait non en
fait il y avait un piège gens pensent
que parce que là qui sont j'ai posé le
key c'est que en fait pour pouvoir
gagner il faut être sûr de connaître la
bonne réponse
après dix neuf coups ce que le 20e et le
dernier il faut qu'on que toute
incertitude et disparus avant ce 20e
cloud qu'il faut que l'entreprise soit
ramenée à 0 après dix neuf cool et en
fait après dix neuf coups comme si je
garde tâche de t1 jusqu'à tes 19 bat
samedi ce sera au plus bon c'est pas
tout à fait le cas parce qu'il y ait
cette fois une possibilité mais
supposant que la personne répond juste
oui ou plus petit moins faire le régal
où ses concurrents
à ce moment là ça serait plus petit que
or l'entropie est plus grande que 19 du
coup avec 19 coups ne peut pas arriver à
réduire notre pied à 0,1
l'entreprise héros c'est à dire qu'il ya
peu aucune certitude c'est à dire que
l'on sait et en fait on va
potentiellement encore hésiter entre
deux nombres après le 19e coup du coup
le 20e coup en fait on hésite encore
entre de 2,2 non il n'est pas sûr de
gagner un port pour vous en convaincre
donc là j'ai pris le cas avec
avec une grande tropiques mais supposer
que
oméga soit juste redire 1 2 3 4
à ce moment-là hd oméga est égale log en
baisse de 2,4 on a vu que ces gars-là 2
ça veut dire que après deux essais je
saurai quelle est la bonne valeur et le
bout du deuxième essai le premier le
premier essai que je donne disons que je
commence avec deux bien il me dit plus
grands bah en fait le deuxième message
je suis encore d'incertitude j'hésite
entre 3 et 4 du coup le deuxième message
ne sera pas vainqueur donc tout ça pour
dire que mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
c'était sur ce qu'elle gérait un écrit
de très spécial et c'est à dire que du
coup la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
malheureusement la bonne réponse c'est
plus en fait il faut 21 coups pour être
sur l'eau bouillie 20e coup on est sur
deux cas la bonne réponse qu'on n'a pas
forcément dit la bonne réponse
et ça en particulier ça veut dire que
pour le cas de notre courbe de notre
score pas tous fait moins 22 points vous
étiez un mois +12
du coup vous passez à moins 10 elle est
un petit peu petit excès de confiance va
dire malencontreux sur cette dernière
réponse avec les cas il est possible que
ça passe en effet si je considère le le
cas où le conseil oui en fait j'ai pas
fait le calcul donc en fait une réponse
preuve
sûr c'est un peu chiant à faire ton
calcul mais probablement non il ya un
écueil arbitres est quasiment un beat ce
qui manque
donc je pense pas que ça ça rajoute
suffisamment de tuer jeu mais quand même
moins 80% de chance pour voir clair et
commence à 90% de chances pour que la
réponse est non en fait il fallait 21
coups pour pouvoir y arriver comme âge
en tout cas c'est l'exemple il
illustrait quelque chose de plus plus
générales vous pouvez vous parler un peu
du jeu est un jeu qui s'appelle qui est
ce jeune que vous connaissez c'est un
jeu où il faut deviner
donc ce que chacun choisit je peux je
fais exactement ça se joue mais bon en
gros chacun un personnage secret à
savoir fois ci avec à d'autres jeux
comme le c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour pour d'autres jeux mais non le cul
est le quai ça c'est assez simple chacun
choisir un personnage et l'autre
personne doit de poser des questions
dont la réponse est oui ou non donc par
exemple si vous êtes les bleus ici donc
j'ai choisi un personnage rouge un
paquet et vous avez le rôle peu de
questions dont par exemple est ce que
l'autre a un chapeau est ce que le vôtre
ton personnage d'un chapeau et si la
personne répond oui c'est à dire que
forcément donc les gens qui ont un
chapeau il n'a pas beaucoup il y en a 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 5
c'est à dire que on peut enlever tous
tous sauf ceux qui ont un chapeau qui
restent ne restera plus que cinq
donc on peut dire que c'est une bonne
chose puisque si jamais d'autres
répondent oui mon personnage est un
chapeau on n'aura plus que 5 cas parmi
lesquels on est président
dans le cas optimiste sais c'est pas mal
mais dans le cas pessimiste mais si on
regarde notamment le pire cas le maximum
le nombre maximum de coups qu'il faudra
deux questions qu'il faudra poser avant
de réduire à un seul cas possibles en
fait c'est une mauvaise stratégie
puisque dans pire car on se retrouve
avec énormément de possibilités on en
aura relevé que cinq parmi parmi 24
on peut se poser la question donc ça
c'est le pire car le meilleur cas on
peut se poser la question en moyenne bas
combien de coups je devrais avoir joué
en moyenne
si je pose cette question et la réponse
est liée à cette entreprise de shannon
et la stratégie optimale
c'est de réduire ce mot incertitude
autant que possible et pour réduire ces
entreprises ont un certain nombre
d'incertitudes autant que possible il
faut jouer le coup qui maximise
l'entropie le conti maximiser
anthropique ans la réponse est oui ou
non sera forcément un coût qui sera de
50 ans qui sera aussi proche de 50 50
que possible non quand même pour
acquérir un maximum d'informations
surtout quand on a des cas assez loin
des cas des problèmes de 10 parce que
notre ville de shannon ça marche très
bien pour le cac continue
quand on a des effets de bord à cause de
cas discret basse-saxe ap par l'autre au
pire elle garde un sens mais il s'est
décrit un peu moins bien l'ensemble des
possibles mais quand on est très proche
des choses très continue notre pinot
shannon est vraiment très proches que ce
qu'on peut faire de mieux et donc en
particulier la courbe que je vous avais
présenté tout à l'heure cette courbe la
celle que je fait clignoter cette courbe
là c'est la courbe ci
on obtenait une information optimale à
chaque test je vous raconte ça fait plus
de deux heures que je parle ne pas finir
beaucoup trop ambitieux est quoi ouais
donc ça ça a eu la cour de rose à ça
correspond qu'à optimale et on ne pourra
pas faire mieux si on a des tests dont
l'issue est binaire on sait qu'on peut
pas faire mieux que ça on peut s'en
rapprocher et l'algorithme de lift est
vraiment pas mal
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour se rapprocher de sa banque schengen
nous l'a déjà dit il faut poser des
questions faire des tests dont l'issue a
une probabilité 1/2 de répondre oui donc
la dent dans le cas des test donc
imaginons que pelé soit très petit
camper très petit à ses moignons fait
des effets de bord et du coup dans
tropic shannon marche beaucoup mieux et
on celle que si un test
6 donc c'est un fait un test groupe et
je reviens avec mes histoires de tech
group et soit il soit il va être positif
ça va être négatif
l'ordi est fatigué
alors
pour ce film a été en prison bon donc le
test aura ça sera maximal mans
informatif donc négatif aurait dit que
c'était avec près d un mois p puissance
cas est donc positif ce sera à moi -
puissance car le test sera maximal mans
ce concept difficile à ce que je peux
faire mieux faire le test sera maximal
mans informatif
si et seulement si donc il ya deux
issues possibles de l'entropie maximale
ségala à un beat et ce sera maximal mans
informatif si et seulement si chaque
issue à une probabilité 1/2 égale 1/2 et
donc savoir si et seulement si cas je
prends le logarithme base de vos côtés
donc ça ça arrive c'est seulement si le
cas bon je vous souhaitez un peu d'états
de culasse à fait moi et puis moi log ça
fait
loeb 2 on sait moins l'ogre bazou
où je veux voir mon thomas arrêté mardi
encore plus fatigué que moi dernier
et donc vous bref en tout cas on peut
utiliser ça pour déterminer quels
seraient des tests
pour montrer aux huissiers sa contrée
que l'algorithme dolly peut pas être aux
petits phares est optimale quand elle
est très très faible et comprend détail
cas est égal à -9 2 - 1 sur pied qui va
être à peu près il ya un sur pied
pendant la première étape après la
deuxième étape en fait on va prendre ça
serait qu'à en fait pour le pour le 2ème
ensuite il pourrait prendre qu'à deux
en fait donc ça va doubler la priorité
ça threat 2 / p une crique agissait
alors de j / p aujourd'hui face à savoir
six iep est très très faible d'un moment
fera réagissez on peut utiliser ça pour
pour faire pour estimer par exemple
efficacité potentielle de des tests des
tests quasi optimaux parce que payer
très grand ça se fait des calculs plus
simple avec les algorithmes de lit avec
des cayes de groupes fixés par paris
ok on va passer ces derniers puissent et
m dernière question
peut-être que si
dernière question c'est si vous pouvez
revenir dans le positif non vous pouvez
pas est ce que marc dupont maximum
dommage donc la question c'est donc
disposant que x est fortement corrélée
avec y
alors en apprenant quelques chaussures y
un bail et gien réduit forcément son
incertitude sur x pas lui faire une
petite pause pendant que vous
réfléchissez à ce que vous y répondez
moi supposons qu'ils sont portés
manquants en corée les sur une vague
alors en apprenant sur y un parisien
arrive forcément son incertitude sur x
et pour préciser quand je dis
incertitudes on est dans le cadre
d'ateliers d'information donc en fait il
faudrait même changé son entropie sur x
en pensant qu'il y ait des nouveaux deux
joueurs restent pas si faible donc une
pour les nouveaux donc je pose cette
énigme là c'est ici que s'est fortement
corrélée avec ibrahim alors en apprenant
sur y avait brisé un réduit forcément
son entropie sur x pourra y répondre
vous allez sur ce lien je surligne et
vous répondez à quel point vous êtes
confiant dans votre réponse dit sûr que
ça soit vrai sur une échelle de 0 à 10
06 vous êtes sûr que c'est faux dit si
c'est sûr que c'est vrai et 5 600 ans
c'est très très incertain
bon
pour l'instant pour rappel sur les
caisses les scènes qu'on a vu quand
vincent pas recensés dans le négatif la
première le premier crise
vous avez été bon je vous avais répondu
8 et pense qu'il devrait donc c'était
coup je faisais remarquer après huit
points ce qui est tu parles du
maquilleur dans le nokia e6 10 points
qu'on peut marquer deuxième crise s'est
il est assez incertain il a répondu
quatre réponses étaient fausses nous
pencher du bon côté barclays 4 contre
c'est pas mal et puis le troisième
cuisent je lui ai répondu je ne sais pas
j'ai tiré 5 0 points et le troisième but
par contre est répandu 9 alors que la
france était fausse
ça fait très très mal le lien ne marche
pas donc s'il ya déjà des réponses donc
le lire à l'air de marcher et alors où
est calculé
donc voilà je regarde le score moyen de
nous payer regarde également votre score
non non sur le deuxième heure
ouais mettre ça dans la description
c'est beaucoup plus simple j'ai pas
pensé une fois je mettrai les liens
description de la vidéo
s'il s'est fortement corrélée avec y
alors en apprenant sur y un baiser a
réduit forcément son incertitude sur x
est souvent trop people prête peu
précise technip en 42 réponse elle 173
personnes qui regardent 77 ap tuerie pas
arriver à 50 peut le faire sans arriver
à 50 sur tous les explications
ouais forcément va fortement
forcément ça veut dire les probabilités
fortement vous pouvez considérer qu'une
corrélation plus que 90 % à venir
ok on attend les 50 réponses voilà ça
donne ça vos réponses donc c'est assez
s'est éparpillé s'est réparti ce qui ce
qu'est ce qu'est ce que je sois un peu
la cscec à quoi ressemble à ça que alors
que ça sera plus la france que ça
ressemble à un truc comme ça c'est vu
des crises et bien d'autres incertitudes
qu'elles sa part un peu des deux côtés
ça tire un peu plus vers la droite
j'aurais dire que ces six la moyenne
notamment il y en a dix qui sont sûrs
que la réponse est oui et un seul car ce
qui est sûr qu'un conseiller
on va dire que votre mode réponse moyen
de ces six toc
ça vous fait quoi comme scores r et
galsi or il se trouve que la réponse est
non on va le perdre et encore 4 points
donc j'ai score global de la journée pas
terrible ça ça finit c'est en tout cas
la réponse est plutôt et en fait non
alors alors pourquoi parce que par ce
qui se passe c'est que donc ça je vais
donner un raisonnement un peu avec ça
peut se formaliser mais l'idée c'est
qu'on soit un contre exemple je
supposais que x est très corrélée avec y
donc souvent sont à noter x et y
bon ben je n'aime pas prendre un exemple
je suis prendre un exemple intuitif que
j'ai un exemple en tête
bon en tout cas il y des deals et c'est
que sur x vous aviez déjà d'incertitudes
donc médian que x basse et c'est vrai ou
faux je ne savais pas si si il c'est
vrai mais vous êtes déjà un a priori et
peut-être que a priori vous pensez que
hicks a de très bonnes chances d'être
vrai par exemple je sais pas je reprends
dire par exemple les écoles vont rouvrir
le 11 mai a priori on dire que le
gouvernement entend rester avec sa
décision donc peut-être que paix est
égal il ya une autre probabilité que x 2
x vrai peut-être qu'elle est proche de
0,6 et le cas en fait vous avez peu
d'incertitude / / / / x h2x ça sera
marché bien là h2x est proche de zéro
peu d'incertitude maintenant c'est
possible que en découvrant y
en fait y avait dans l'autre sens et en
fait il y eu ça se trouve
se trouvent y suggère que x e
quelques y suggère que x en fait pas si
vrai que ça donc c'est possible que que
après était de x sachant y reviennent à
0,5
sachant que y est égale une certaine
valeur peut-être qu'à une valeur de y
pour laquelle qui kiffent qui suggère
l'opposé en fait à ce moment là h2x
sachant que notre pi 2 x sachant que
greg à la grecque
dans ce cas elle sera égale art aussi
comprendre et profite à 0,5 et donc vous
voyez que en gagnant de l'information
sur va de très corrélé avec y
vous pouvez augmenter votre certitude ça
c'est important à noter c'est à dire que
va peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
en fait je suis quasiment sûr que que
tout ira bien dans cette crise c'est
avec la même veine on peut prendre un
verre c'est parce qu'il y avait créé un
peu plus aujourd'hui je suis assez
pessimiste
pour être honnête sur l'avancée de la
pandémie et j'ai l'impression qu'on se
prépare pas très bien et du coup j'ai
une probable une probabilité assez
grande
en fait qu'on aura besoin d'un second
confinement à peut-être que ma priorité
d'un second confinement c'était très
robert gül lui comme à dire mais le
surnom de confinement et être très
corrélé avec l'utilisation du contact
racing par exemple et peut-être que je
suis sceptique aujourd'hui sur
utilisation d'un contact res inefficace
c'est un mauvais exemple
non hier avec les tests de dépistage
massif ça me paraît un pro peu probable
aujourd'hui conteste qu'on arrive à
tester toute la population française
toutes les semaines on va dire le
premier jour mais si mais le fait qu'on
teste les gens de façon massif est très
corrélée avec le fait qu' on n'est pas
besoin de son confinement
donc aujourd'hui je pense que la
probabilité d'un second confinement un
exemple concret selon les étés teyana
0,8 donc l'entropie un peu la calculer
voilà je peux la calculer je vous amener
la calcul aurait calculé h20 8.8 c'est
0,7 qu'on sait pas si faible mais c'est
0,7
maintenant je suppose que je découvre la
valeur de quelque chose qui est très
corrélée avec x second confinement et il
se trouve que je découvre que dépistage
massif en fête aura lieu
ça veut pas dire que je suis sûr que le
qu'il n'y aura pas de confinement a
saisi c'est possible que malgré ce
dépistage massif on en arrive
mais malgré tout besoin de confinement
du coup peut-être qu'à cause de ça je
passais à 0,5 auquel cas h approche doit
donc l'incertitude peut augmenter au fur
à mesure qu'on acquiert plus
d'informations ça peut paraître un peu
intuitif mais je pense que ça
intéressant à noter c'est que
l'incertitude sur quelque chose peut
augmenter
hop en acquérant les informations alors
hyacinthe et ron qui va dans le sens que
je vais démontrer sa ya antoine qui va
dans le sens même de ce que j'ai
prétendu tout à l'heure donc donc non
donc ce qu'on a vu jouer vite et si
c'est donc c'est que un test en
particulier peut augmenter l'incertitude
si le test est un parfait c'est un test
un parfait c'est pas augmenter
incertitude est un autre exemple
pardon si vous êtes coupe positif si
vous êtes positif aucune comme si vous
avez le convient de vous avez un test
qui dit que vous êtes positif au
qu'ovide et que le test est pas fiable à
100% ça va augmenter votre probabilité
d'être positif avec au vide aussi avant
le test vous aviez une priorité de 0,1
pour cent dans un post doit important
dix ans d'être positif à la coved
le fait d'avoir ce test qui est
fortement corrélée le fait d'avoir ça va
augmenter autre incertitude est
peut-être que vous avez passé maintenant
à profiter de 50 pour soi ça veut dire
que le test comme bashmet samitier par
50 la priorité que dès que vous ayez un
peu vide mais du coup maintenant l'autre
incertitude sur est ce que vous avez à
coville est devenue énorme d'entropie a
beaucoup augmenté
avec cette information du coup c'est
possible on peut avoir
h2x ça chantait et galt est supérieur à
jeu x
c'est le dernier truc que je vais faire
aujourd'hui j'ai pris part de beaucoup
plus de choses même mort dit être en
train de rendre l'âme
et puis on se rapproche des 3 heures m
donc ça c'est possible mais ellis un
théorème qui est intéressant
l'envié très fatigué
théorème le théorème me dit que ce qu'on
va appeler nos tropiques conditionnelle
de x ça chantait
alors notre pays conditionnent c7
l'espérance parce que je tire t une
incertitude sachant x 22 x ça chante et
ça c'est une définition cette entropie
l'a7 entrepris conditionnelle par contre
elle va être plus petit que l'entropie
sur x
et en fait ça ça vient d'atteindre sa
soeurette l'on est approuvé le choix du
var étaient là mardi dans l'âme mais mes
sketches de preuves fait ce qui se passe
c'est que l'entropie sur la valeur ça va
prendre à accorder des lives trop long
en fait ça c'est l'entropie sur les deux
variables à foix c'est une incertitude à
foix sur le test et sur la valeur de x
ça en fait on peut démontrer que c'est
galles-france un calcul ans et il n'y a
rien de lui décrire le calcul pour
utiliser les voies des produits des
conditionnels mais c'est ya rien de
non pas tout à fait ça c'est pas comme
ça qu'on prouve
d'andiran là il veut plus
un tracé c'est l'information mutuelle
réd mardi le peuple qu'est ce que je
veux prouver en lames je vais écrire la
preuve ici donc le théorème dit que h x
ça chantait et plus petits plus petits
veaux égale htx et pourrait la
démonstration
enfin une façon en fait ça revient à
étudier ce rappel le l'information
mutuelle entre x et hey l'information de
mutuelle entre x et hey ça se regarde
c'est un peu compliqué d'expliquer son
traitement en gros c'est dans
l'incertitude sur sur le x en offrant
gros hic c était son très corrélé quand
l'information mutuelle est très grande
c'est quand il ya beaucoup
d'informations qu'on peut déduire
beaucoup de choses sur l'excision
connectés et beaucoup de choses sur
sûreté si on connaît donc cette
information
mutuelle en fait on peut démontrer
qu'elle est égal avec le x - hpx ça
chantait
et on peut montrer on peut le définir
comme ça on peut montrer épi est positif
voilà pourquoi ça serait très cool
montrer tout ça mais bon j'ai plus
d'outils pour
vérifiez que je dis pas de bêtises aussi
bon voila il à se dire que en moyenne
l'information va baisser en moyenne
enfin l'incertitude va baisser en
moyenne plus on collecte de données sur
tes qu'une autre incertitude diminue
malgré tout même si c'est palais s'est
pas dit que dans un cadre pratique ça va
vraiment baissé en tête l'incertude peut
augmenter
km 18 distinction importante à faire à
ce niveau là voilà donc mon ordi est un
peu en train de rendre l'âme à voir je
vois s'il ya des besoins de rendre ça
plus viables mais en tout cas je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi
je suis déjà ne pas voir peut-être que
je reviendrai sur notre live vous paraît
plus de ces histoires d'information
mutuel et la formation conditionnelle ou
est ce que c'est quand même des trucs
que et c'est de voir aussi comment on va
appliquer ça pour faire des tests
je finis en décrivant l'idée de sujets
de recherche que j'ai en tête et je
précise des chercheurs parmi vous ça
peut ça se passe un truc intéressant
c'est l'idée c'est de d'optimiser du
coup les tests pour savoir pour
optimiser les tests faut qu être capable
de calculer notamment nos tropiques
typiquement un test est là jusqu'à il se
pose est que tout était indépendant
identiquement distribués mais s'il ya
des clusters de gens des gens qui vivent
ensemble ou qui travaillent ensemble tu
veux avoir décoration plus forte
une façon assez naturelle de décrire ça
en termes de modèles deesing enfin des
trucs les homos d'aliasing en tout cas
de modèles design je pense que ça marche
très bien et si on s'appuie avec un
modèle deesing on peut se poser
étant donné un modèle deesing même une
discussion sur des modèles désigne
comment est-ce qu'on peut identifier les
groupes attester de sorte que la
probabilité que ce groupe soit à tester
et proches par exemple de la priorité
que ce groupe soit poésie soit proche
d'un demi ça c'est du coup ça ne nous
rapprocherait de la borne de shannon et
en pratique on peut même se demander
comment est ce qu'on fait en tout cas
plusieurs étapes
comment optimiser sa et c'est loin
d'être stupide parce que avec les
données du contact racing on pourrait
vraiment avoir ce graphe pour vraiment
avoir un graphe france un modèle deesing
avec des corrélations locales comme ça
qui permettrait ensuite de poser
vraiment ce problème il ya vraiment une
application de pratiques et peut-être
qu'on utilise en saas et on peut
regarder qu'à doubler si on peut doubler
le nombre de personnes testées dépister
avec un nombre fixe et le test ça ça
peut avoir des conséquences assez énorme
donc françois qu'on arrive à doubler
mais si on arrive à augmenter de 50% ça
sera vraiment c'est un sujet de
recherche que je jette là si on a qui
veulent s'y intéresser
et oui je pense pas avoir le temps de
dieu de nous occuper vraiment mais que
je vous remercie de votre attention
je sais que homo fabulous est un
chercheur en psychologie des
authentiques mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la bonne expertise du cas merci
d'avoir suivi et je vous dis à à une
prochaine fois